everybody should go ham from 22 to 30
and do a ton of ridiculous and figure
themselves out before you can be a
painter who can paint what's beyond mere
memory you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and a lot of that is
painful repetition and hard grinding
work I didn't find my passion until long
after college wanna be happy build a
life not just a business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back it lack a belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the best advice
from young people from some of the most
successful people on the planet
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one take risks with Gary Vaynerchuk I'm
not sure anybody is taking enough risk
from 20 to 30 it is the most interesting
thing that I've been thinking about
which is it is never more practical to
be disproportionately risky than from 22
to 30 yet everybody goes the other way
because now they're the real world and
it's time to prove something to their
parents to themselves to everybody else
and everybody goes conservative it is a
huge mistake we need to flip it upside
down everybody should go ham from 22 to
30 and do a ton of ridiculous and figure
themselves out five but on your own dime
not your parents there's the parents
clapping so so how I think about it is
you should go and be rogue and get to
know yourself and taste from 22 to 30
but you have to live by the
ramifications of doing that and the cost
of entry of that is living with four
people in a studio apartment eating dog
food and not having fancy shoes when you
go and do that but you're being
subsidized by your parents then you're
living in a fake environment and you're
super tell us about failure and why it's
important to I love it yeah because you
I love it
I like micro failure I like micro
failure I hate macro failure like death
of your business is bad but but to me
you know it's funny I'll use a boxing
analogy my favourite boxing man i watch
a lot of boxing
I think boxing is a very interesting and
I know and I'm super into mixed martial
arts but I grew up
boxing I understand it better and I like
watching it because there's so many
things that happen in boxing first of
all what I love about boxing is there's
nowhere to hide you know like it's super
interesting right there's nowhere to
hide number two there's something
there's a scenario boxing that I love
the most
there's for some reason there's nothing
more interesting to me than watching
somebody get knocked down in the first
round and then go on to win the fight
easily it's an interesting psyche right
and I like that and this is what I'm
thinking about it which is like here's
what's bad in boxing and in business
going into a fight getting knocked the
[ __ ] out in the first round and losing
the match bad getting knocked down and
then having the adversity to readjust to
what you got caught on and navigating it
too easily when a fight is remarkable
that's how I think about
entrepreneurship people the reason so
many people struggle with
entrepreneurship is you have micro
failures almost daily and they're very
in-your-face
you can't hide and I like that I like
failure I because I think I deserve it I
hate when people don't respect the game
when I fail it means I've thought and I
like that because I think people get
audacious my number one thing that I
hate about capitalism is that people use
it and they love it and they're big
capitalists and they love open market
and competition and all that and then
they become 73 and they try to use all
their money to protect their money
they're not willing to let a young lion
eat them the way they ate somebody else
I hate when they try to manipulate it
that's what I love about sports what I
love about sports is when you're 36 and
you were once the best player in the
league but now you're getting a little
bit older and your body breaks down you
are forced to retire the one thing that
entrepreneurship and capitalism has to
adjust to is once you get old and you're
tired and you want to be on a yacht
instead of working you're you should
lose some money because you're losing
rule number two ask the right questions
with Elon Musk when you were in college
developing these skills you want to do
some things that were of benefit to
humanity
that why why did you think that well
because not everyone does yeah no I
guess it was sort of a existential
crisis of like what does it all mean and
what's the mini you know what's the
meaning of life and there's 3 a.m. over
a beer or probably goes back to high
school I guess I don't to give a lavoris
the long answer but I was Modar
childhood it wasn't good probably
partially brought on but by reading some
of the fluff is like don't ever read
Schopenhauer Nietzsche if you're 14
that's it's not good now or I'd ran
either yeah yeah so I was just trying to
find figure out what you know what does
well mean and actually when I read The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy I think
it's a great work philosophy that sort
of highlight at the point that very
often the issue is understanding what
questions to ask and if you can properly
frame the question then the answer is
the easy part so I thought things that
expand the scope and scale of human
consciousness and allow us to better ask
questions and you know and and and
achieve greater enlightenment those are
good things and so that's what what can
we do that's gonna most likely lead to
that outcome also if you want to have
more motivation and confidence check out
my 254 series they're free the link to
join on the description below my ability
to only be comfortable in massive chaos
has been my biggest asset as an
entrepreneur like I would never take a
note like that scares the piss out of me
what these three people are doing right
now there are times when something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do you do it in spite of the
fear I want you all to stay true to the
most real most sincere most authentic
parts of yourselves rule number three
sacrifice with Jordan Peterson before
you can be a painter who can paint
what's beyond mere memory you you have
to inculcate that discipline skill and a
lot of that is painful repetition and
hard grinding work
it's the sacrifice of the present for
the future but once you manage that then
things open up and virtually everything
you learn of value is like that's very
very very difficult to learn to write
and there's arbitrary arbitrary rules
that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're you're a rank beginner
and and even to some degree whatever
creativity you have is going to have to
be stifled well you're passing through
that that keyhole but if you pass
through it then something massive opens
up on the other side and it is
definitely the case that disciplinary
institutions universities are exactly
that is their places of guidance and and
their places to encourage people to
develop the discipline that's necessary
to see beyond the discipline I mean
that's why we have disciplines right I
mean the words aren't there by accident
you have to narrow yourself first and
then you can broaden outward and so
that's and that's part of the process of
maturation that part of the that's part
of the sacrifice of childhood say in
childhood you're nothing but potential
but it's not realized and you don't know
how to realize it and so then the
question is well how do you get to a
point where you realize the potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single Direction this is
Nietzsche's commentary on the Catholic
Church because a great admirer of the
Catholic Church despite the fact that he
was also a radical critic a critic of
Christianity said the count see the
thing about the Catholic Church is that
it forced everything to be interpreted
within a single explanatory framework
and that was a discipline and once that
discipline was established then the
disciplined mind could explode in every
direction which is precisely what
happened and so and and and that's the
thing about growing up is that when
you're a teenager and a young adult you
have to sacrifice everything you could
have been as a child to be the one thing
that you're aiming at but then that
opens up and and the universities are
part and parcel of that process and you
need the guidance because the the the
library is too large to wander through
it unaided
number four find your passion with
Michelle Obama I didn't find my passion
until long after college heck until
after law school I mean the truth is I
spent still spent way too much of my
time at Princeton continuing to chase
grades and checkboxes and climb higher
and higher I went on to law school I did
the same thing by the time I was in my
mid-20s I had everything I was told I
should want fancy job at a prestigious
law firm a big office a nice paycheck
but on the inside something was missing
and so after a few knocks I finally
asked myself some big questions simple
questions what did I want out of my life
what makes me happy what do I care about
yeah simple questions that I had never
bothered to ask too busy checking boxes
and soon I realized that what I really
wanted was pretty simple I wanted to
give back to the people around me to the
world around me I wanted to live my life
by the principle that to whom much is
given much is expected
so for me
that led me to quit that fancy job and
since then I've dedicated my life to
giving back I've work to train young
people for careers in public service
I've started community outreach programs
at a college in a hospital and today is
first lady I'm working to honor our
nation's military families and help our
children grow up healthy but as I look
back I wish I'd asked myself what I
really wanted when I was sitting right
where you are so graduates my message to
all of you today is this
do not waste a minute living someone
else's dream each of us has unique gifts
[Applause]
but it takes a lot of work a lot of real
work to discover what brings you joy it
just doesn't happen it requires you
spending you some time and you won't
find what you love simply by checking
boxes or padding your GPA you won't
figure it out only by listening to your
guidance counselor your friends or even
your parents you can only find your
passion by looking inside yourself and
you'll number five the last one before a
very special bonus clip is work super
hard with Bill Gates I think you know
you can over a worship and mythologize
the idea of working extremely hard for
my particular makeup I mean it really is
true that I didn't believe in weekends I
didn't believe in vacations I mean you
know I knew everybody's license plate so
I could tell you over the last month
when their car had come and gone from
the parking lot so I don't recommend it
a I don't think most people would enjoy
it once I got into my 30s I could hardly
even imagine how I had done that because
by then some natural behavior kicked in
and I loved weekends and you know my
girlfriend liked vacations and that
turned out to be kind of a neat thing
now I take lots of vacations my 20 year
old self is so disgusted with my current
self you know I I was sure I would never
do anything but riding coach you know
now I have a plane so it's very much
counter revelations have taken place at
high speed but yes it is nice if during
those first several years if you have a
team that's chosen to be pretty maniacal
about the company and how far that goes
you know should have a mutual
understanding see or not one person
expecting one thing another person
expecting another thing and you'll have
individuals who who have you know health
or relatives or things that are
distracted me yes I have a fairly
hardcore view that there should be a
very large
sacrifice made during those those early
years now I have a special bonus clip
from Andrew yang on how to do what you
love that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching a video to taking action
here we go question number one what is
your passion number two what's the risk
that you need to take to grow your
business and number three what's the
right question that you should be asking
yourself today and if you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well you want and what I say
to young people and this is gonna sound
like that like post movie advice you got
that there is a period where like I
don't believe that advice but it's going
to become better advice over time it's
really important to find something that
you enjoy and like because if you enjoy
it then you're more likely to invest
time in it and become good at it and
develop like skills that are resilient
over time so believe it or not if you're
a young person you can find something
you really enjoy doing
you should lean into that and a lot of
that revolves around interpersonal
dynamics and skills because team
building is going to become crucial over
time and in a world where you know
dealing with people is going to become a
massive value-add so that that's one
thing I would say is and it sounds like
80s movies advice or something but if
you can find something you like doing
just really trying it good at it
if you want to know the pros and cons of
education check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there good morning believe nation is it
a good idea to get a higher education
we're gonna answer that question in
today's episode of believe life